good morning it's a pleasure to have a
chance to speak during the bio
conference live this year I'm cinnamon
gloss from the Scripps translational
Science Institute in la jolla california
and this morning i'll be talking about
return of genome sequencing results to
physicians and patients and i just want
to add before i start please feel free
to submit your questions and i will
address them at the end of the talk
alright so um in order to get at some of
the issues around return of results and
genome sequencing I'd like to focus on
describing a bit about an initiative we
have ongoing at Scripps that we call our
idiom study or idiopathic diseases of
man study where we are trying to utilize
sequencing for diagnosis and treatment
of idiopathic diseases and this is a
study where we are recruiting cases
where the patient has been essentially
on a diagnostic Odyssey has had you know
every a medical procedure and test under
the Sun and but has yet to have an
answer as to what their diagnosis is or
how if at all it can be treated we
started this project in the fall of two
thousand eleven so it's been going on
for about two years now and we've
enrolled our tenth patient in the study
but I'll be focusing on describing the
first five cases that we've enrolled
gonna use some kind of very early case
study data on return of results and also
describing a bit about the procedures um
the cases themselves that are how we
return results in this study and most
importantly describing some of the
lessons that we've learned so far
in conducting this project so the main
points of interest that I deven chua Lee
like you all to take away from this is
to get a sense of what are the
characteristics of the physicians and
patients that were seeing in the context
of this study importantly and as you'll
see these patients and physicians are
unique and may not in fact be
representative of all the types of
patients who may ultimately benefit from
clinical sequencing also what are sort
of the attitudes and expectations of
both the physicians and the patients
that you have signed up for a study like
this what do they do they have false
hope that's been a concern in the
literature what types of data did they
expect access to do they expect to know
findings from clinical sequencing beyond
just results that may pertain to the
presenting condition for which they've
been on the diagnostic Odyssey that's
been a big debate in the field for the
past few years is the issue of kind of
secondary or incidental findings and to
what extent do we look for these in
clinical sequencing analysis and then to
what extent are those results returned
so i'll be talking a bit about that and
also importantly in our study the way
that our protocol works is that we
actually have the physicians themselves
receive the results from us and then
it's really up to them as to how they
return those results to the patients and
the families and you know sort of what
aspects of the results they deliver and
we've been sort of closely studying this
process as a way to just better
understand how how well equipped if at
all physicians feel to be able to do
this this type of work so I'll show a
little bit of data early data that we've
collected pertaining to that issue just
a bit about
self the the criteria for enrollment the
patients that are enrolled in any M we
we actually enrolled a patient and then
the biological parents so the a trio the
patient has to have a condition that's
in grave or severe you have not
life-threatening severely quality of
life threatening the condition has to
have been undiagnosed despite as I
mentioned the floor extensive medical
follow-up the symptoms need to appear
genetic and to have the potential for
improvement via sequencing so the you
know we need me to have a sense that the
sequencing would be informative for the
case also this this hasn't been an issue
for too many of the patients that we've
enrolled to date but because they're at
this point in time there is a can be a
Turner a turnaround time issue for
sequencing we look for cases where
there's a life expectancy consistent
with again being able to benefit from
those sequencing results and then
finally a very important piece of our
study is that there needs to be a
physician champion who is willing to
actively participate and engage with the
research team on behalf of the patient
and also be willing to take
responsibility for the return of results
okay a bit about idiom procedures um
cases are referred they their option
referred from physicians from but also
from family members from the patients
are often self-referred as well they
undergo an initial screening by a nurse
coordinator who works on the project
here at Scripps cases that appear to
meet sort of general criteria for the
study are then forwarded for review to
our clinician scientist review panel
that's made up of a group of about 2 15
positions um who are sort of on call for
are you know a series of review meetings
that happen roughly quarterly and then
also members of the research team
including bioinformatics specialists
sequencing specialists psychologists and
ethics people as well we also have
membership from our representation from
our IRB on that panel for cases that the
panel chooses to enroll based on the
criteria they then you know provide
their blood for sequencing and analysis
and then prior to actually receiving
results we do a psychosocial and ethics
assessment or pre and post sequencing
which I'll describe in a minute and
importantly um in the context of our
current protocol the way that return of
results works is that we we are only at
this time returning primary results that
pertain to the presenting condition but
are very interested in expanding the
protocol potentially to include return
of secondary findings and so it's one
reason that we've been very interested
in kind of collecting some initial data
from these patients based on you know
what are their preferences for a return
of results importantly we also only
return results to the patient you know
potentially because parents are being
sequenced as well you could imagine that
there may be results in the parent
genomes that could be relevant so we we
asked about that as well um we wouldn't
what we conduct the analysis develop the
results put it into a report that report
is given to the physician champion the
physician champion has been offered the
opportunity to have a sit down and meet
with our research team to go over those
results to really try to support that
position as much as possible in his or
her delivery of the results to the
patient and his or her
possibly utilizing the results in the
patient's care as I mentioned before we
have a very dedicated group of
scientists and clinicians who serve on
our review panel most many of our
meetings take place in the evenings or
at lunch so it is quite a dedicated
group and as you can see here it's also
representative of really a range of
medical specialties neurology internal
medicine allergy immunology and so forth
the psychosocial piece of our assessment
protocol we like to get at a number of
different sort of facets of the process
so trying to better understand what are
the patient characteristics associated
with kind of this unique population what
are the physician characteristics our
physicians that might tend to refer
patients for a sequencing study like
this do they differ from your average
position in certain ways for example you
can imagine that perhaps a physician's
willing to do this might be more
recently trained having had more
exposure to genetics potentially or
perhaps they just take sort of a more
innovative attitude towards medical care
are among the first in their peer group
group to adopt new medical treatments or
interventions and so these are things
that we try to try to measure and better
understand we also ask both patients and
physicians about kind of different
aspects of their attitudes towards the
sequencing so you know do they have any
concerns about privacy concerns about
being able to interpret the findings as
I mentioned earlier what are their
preferences for return of findings that
secondary findings or incidental
findings if those findings were
available in our protocol would they
want them we asked about that
um and then very importantly we also
seek to find out more about sort of the
actual communication of the results
themselves we do that via an instrument
called the medical communication
competence scale I'll describe a bit
more about that a bit later but this is
really focused on sort of how well the
physician actually delivers their
genomic sequencing results compared to
how well they communicate in general so
hopefully we'll be able to show you some
of our early data that may sort of pique
your interest about this particular
issue and then finally post sequencing
we also asked about the impact of the
sequencing itself to do either the
patient or the position or the parents
have any regrets about undergoing
sequencing how impactful was the
sequencing was it distressing and so
forth just to give you a sense we've to
date we've received 101 referrals for
our idiom study over the past two years
they've come from all over the US and
also we've had a number of international
referrals as well although certainly the
majority of cases are from ifornia
what's the California you know these are
sort of the specialties and types that
are represented among these referrals
and we've been tracking this closely
many of you may be aware of the program
at the NIH called the undiagnosed
diseases program and that group has has
published a number of kind of
information about their program
including the specialties represented
the number of referrals and so forth and
so we've been tracking this as well to
try to get some idea of sort of the
overlap in specialties seen by be by are
two different programs
also the most common specialties
observed and as you can see here by far
and neurology is sort of
over-represented among this referral
population and is very consistent with
with what the UDP is seeing as well if
they published data suggesting that
certain neurology is of one of their top
specialties as well we're also seeing
hematology oncology cardiology at
allergy immunology in the number of
other specialties as well okay so just
some some data on our referrals as a
function of whether they're not they
were deemed ineligible versus whether or
not they went to a full panel review and
what you can see here is that the panel
has reviewed roughly thirty three
percent of the cases that we've received
and you know clearly from these data you
know we're much more likely to see cases
that would that we feel would be
appropriate that meet inclusion criteria
among sort of the younger the end of the
spectrum in terms of cases that are
reviewed and when you simply look at
sort of proportion of cases that are
children under 18 much higher proportion
among the cases that our panel has
reviewed similarly as I mentioned before
our referrals can come from they can
self-referred referred by family member
or by a physician and you can see that
cases that are referred by a physician
helps also much more likely to make it
cut it to the next stage of panel review
and then you can also see sort of the
top medical specialties that are
represented neurology is high for both
groups but then once you get to the
panel review stage we're seeing on
oncology allergy immunology and
cardiology being more common
okay now I'd like to talk a little bit
about sort of some case study data from
our very first cases that we've enrolled
in this study this is um data on our
cases one through five you can see the
age range represented here ages 14 to 35
most of them have been female all most
of them have been European of European
ancestry and as I mentioned before we
also like to get a sense of the
patient's kind of self rated quality of
life using kind of a validated measure
of this and so um the we kind of asked
about three different domains of quality
of life including physical psychological
and environmental and what you can see
here I'm showing some z-scores here
compared to to normative average and not
surprising based on the inclusion
criteria for the study we're seeing that
this group of patients has kind of
severely impaired physical quality of
life very consistent with having you
know very serious illness they they fall
at about average in terms of their
psychological and emotional quality of
life which could be expected I suppose
um but what I think is interesting is
when we ask that environmental quality
of life so things like how well
supported they feel by sort of family
how you know to what extent they feel
they have financial resources those
sorts of things actually seeing superior
quality of life among these patients and
I think this is important and it's not
really an issue that gets discussed all
that much in these types of studies but
I think what this suggests is that the
types of patients were seeing in these
early studies are really um you know and
this is borne out by our observations as
well but they're really very
sophisticated families typically very
highly educated um
in to some extent this makes sense
because really to have been on a
diagnostic Odyssey to some extent a
family or a patient has to be too savvy
enough to you know to kind of work
through the medical system and so I
think this is important because you know
it suggests that there's probably a lot
of other patients out there who aren't
as savvy who don't have as many
financial resources you know that could
still benefit from sequencing and I
think you know as a as a field and as a
community thinking through ways to reach
out to those types of patients is going
to be important going forward we're also
seeing among this group of patients kind
of a high average and all a genetic
knowledge score so again kind of feeding
into this idea that these are sort of a
more savvy not your typical group of
patients and so what about the
physicians so um characteristics of the
physician champions for these first five
cases kind of arranged in terms of when
they completed their training these are
the specialties that are represented and
in terms of the time that they've spent
caring for the patient it kind of ranges
from seven months to several years so a
sort of a range that we're seeing there
we also asked about as I mentioned
before and sort of where physicians fall
in terms of how likely they are to adopt
new procedures and technologies in
general are they is it are they more
likely than their peers to do that and
so forth and in fact what we're seeing
here this is the personal innovativeness
at the bottom of this table is that they
actually in the average range so this
isn't really a group of physicians but
are tremendous outliers in the sons but
in fact they're they're more average
okay so now I'd like to move a bit to
the issue of secondary findings
preferences for secondary findings and
what we're seeing in our data I put
these from these early cases so bear in
mind this is case study data certainly
not making a lot of strong inferences
from this but just as a reminder so
secondary findings are findings from
clinical sequencing or really any
medical tests that are sort of unrelated
to the referral question or the reason
why the person underwent sequencing or
the other medical tests in the first
place and so we we asked about
preferences for secondary funds we asked
the physicians we asked the patients and
we asked the parents and I mean you
could imagine you know that these groups
might differ in terms of what their
preferences are for instance we had a
physician who you know who in general
wanted to receive secondary findings but
expressed concern that findings for a
parent of her patient would she would
receive secondary finding for the parent
of her patient given that that parent
isn't actually her patient so there's
you know there's some reasons why we
might expect to see different
preferences among these different groups
and so what we're asking here in the
data that i'm going to show you our data
from our pre sequencing assessment and
we're asking whether or not they would
want to receive secondary findings in
different categories for them so you can
see here these bars represent centage of
patients out of the 55 patients by
physicians and then 10 parents that were
surveyed and here we're asking them
about whether they would want to receive
findings for childhood onset conditions
where there really wasn't any screening
or treatment available for that
condition and so we're seeing you know
sixty to seventy percent of individuals
in our study saying yes I would
definitively want these results if they
were available
when you go up to adult onset alzheimers
for example where there are no screening
or treatment available we see that your
parents kind of took up to one hundred
percent one hundred percent of them are
saying yes i would want those findings
for myself among patients and physicians
it's still roughly around sixty percent
when we go down to childhood onset
confer which screening and treatment is
available we're seeing eighty to ninety
percent of parents patients and
physicians wanting access to these
results finally when we're dealing with
adult onset conditions where there is
screening and treatment available one
example might be breast cancer a hundred
percent of people in these groups would
want to get those findings back we also
asked about the extent to which these
groups would want findings related to
kind of susceptibility to adverse drug
reactions and similarly we're seeing a
very high percentage of individuals in
these groups wanting those results back
and I will tell you that when we
reassessed all of these different
categories after sequencing so post
sequencing after the patients and the
families had already received their
primary results in every case the
percentage that wanted these findings in
the different categories actually went
up so suggesting that there's there's
quite a strong interest at least in
theory in getting these results that I
think it's important that you know to
some extent when you ask patients about
you know extent to which they would want
these results if they were available
it's kind of a theoretical question i
think you know until you know they're
there you know they're in that situation
it's you know in there was actually that
that that possibility sort of sitting in
front of them there there could
conceivably be different attitudes about
that but i think
at this point it's it's important to
kind of take note that that patients are
saying yes we we want these results okay
so I just want to digress from talking
about data from our study for a minute
and just talk a little bit about this
issue of secondary findings given that
it's it's been such a controversial
issue in the literature in particular
last March the American College of
medical genetics and genomics actually
came out with their official
recommendations regarding how labs
should deal with secondary findings and
came came out with a list of conditions
and genes and variants where patients
really shouldn't have a choice they
would really it would be a requirement
of undergoing sequencing that patients
receive those findings and these
recommendations have been very
controversial and have really prompted a
lot of opinions pieces and commentaries
about this general area and one thing
that I think is very interesting about
this is and the extent to which we
really have empirical data that can
inform our sort of policies and
procedures about returning secondary or
incidental findings these data that I'm
showing in this slide here were compiled
by a postdoc in my lab Debbie bolt who's
been very interested in this area and
reviewing the literature on secondary
and incidental findings and you know
what you can see here is that you know
there have been a lot of sort of
opinions and commentary pieces published
over the last few years on this issue
there's been some data on people sort of
attitudes and perceptions of you know
whether or not these findings should be
available we've seen some reviews we've
seen some studies that have estimated
what the actual frequency or likelihood
of seeing incidental findings would be
in any given population but when we go
down to studies that have actually um
you know to some extent return
incidental findings and actually sort of
measure
impact of doing that there have been
very very very few and so I think it's
it's important to consider how as a
field we might start to do more
empirical studies on and what the actual
impact of different policies towards
incidental findings might actually be
okay so now I'd like to talk a little
bit about the return of results between
the physician and the patient and some
of the data we've seen in our in our
study and so um what I'd like to ask you
to do right now is to think about the
last time or last few times you saw your
own physician and think about how you
would rate your physician in terms of
their knowledge of the issues you
brought to them their explanation see
you of those issues the extent to which
he or she solicited your your questions
the extent to which he or she spent time
and you know appropriate amount of time
answering questions repeating
information just kind of the overall
their overall communication report card
if you will so I would like you to think
about that a bit as as we go through
these next few slides so we essentially
ask this question of patients in our
idiom study and what you can see here
i'm going to show you data for the first
five cases the axis the y-axis reflects
scores on the medical communication
competence scale and the blue bars that
i'm showing here represent how the
patient rated their physician in general
so this was done pre sequencing and we
said have you know how does your
physician do generally in terms of
explaining things in terms of their
knowledge in terms of soliciting your
questions and so forth and what you can
see here is that looks part among these
five cases patients are saying you know
our physician does a great job
they explain things very well so what we
did then was during in the post
sequencing assessment we ask the patient
to do the same thing but to specifically
comment on the physicians communication
around the return of the sequencing
results themselves and this is what
we're seeing Oh four cases one and two
you can see that in general patients
were very satisfied in terms of the
physicians return of sequencing results
and very comparable to how the physician
um sort of communicated with them in
general what we see however for cases
three and four are a bit of a
discrepancy where the patient is
essentially saying actually a the
physician didn't didn't do as well with
returning sequencing results as he or
she does in general so then what we did
in this protocol is that we also asked
the physician to didn't kind of rate him
or herself on how they did with regard
to return of sequencing results just to
see how well that mapped on to how the
patient view that return of results
encounter and what you can see here is
that the four cases one and two the you
know that the findings are pretty
consistent we're seeing you know fairly
high ratings by the physician the
patient in the fish and the patient
excuse me however when we start to get
into case three a a little bit
problematic we're seeing a physician who
has said actually I did a fairly good
job of returning those results but this
is kind of a discrepancy from how the
patient viewed that return of results
session essentially the patient gave the
physician sort of a failing grade if you
will with regard to return results and
then in case for that's also sort of an
interesting case we're seeing that
Shin felt that he or she did a poor job
of returning results even though the
patient felt that you know it was it was
fine to delve in a little bit deeper
into case three and show you a bit about
what the what the patient and the
physician of the family actually
reported with respect to this return of
results encounter what you're seeing
here is a x axis of the different
questions sampling of the different
questions we asked so knowledge about
genetics knowledge about whole genome
sequencing how well the physician
explained what the results were repeat
reviewed or repeated important
information ensured that the patient
understood encouraged the patient asked
questions but enough time and then also
how did the session go over all and so
of the in this is case 3 once again in
the one where we found a significant
discrepancy and I'm going to should be
showing you results for physician mom
and dad and so what you can see here is
that these are the data from the
physician in red and I was fairly
actually received the physicians
assessment back first for this case and
was encouraged to see that this
physician felt that that they did a
quite a good job at at these various
domains for the return of results we
received the results back from dad and
it's interesting what we're seeing here
is that mom and dad agreed that in fact
the physician did seem quite
knowledgeable about genetics
knowledgeable about whole genome
sequencing however when we asked mom and
dad or some of these other issues with a
pretty striking discrepancy between how
mom and dad view that return of results
versus how the physician viewed it it's
you know there's a lot of when we asked
mom and dad you know how well
position explain what the results were
they they they basically disagree but
this position did a good job in this
case mom was a little bit more forgiving
than dad but in general both of them
were pretty dissatisfied with the return
of results overall so um actually going
back to this and this actually prompted
for this particular case to provide a
bit of background when we saw these
results we actually reached out to a
different position on this patients team
and actually conducted a second return
of results to try to sort of alleviate
this particular issues so we we learned
a lot from this case and so you know
these these issues around
miscommunication obviously can lead to
mistakes misunderstandings between
patient and physician as well as just
general frustration on the part of both
parties and certainly with case 3 I
would I will say that the family was it
was very frustrated so I think you know
it's only one case but can be
instructive for thinking about return of
results in these types of cases so what
about post sequencing some of our other
observations didn't we a one example is
that kind of some themes that we've seen
the physician from case one said and
this was a physician where both parties
thought that the return of results look
very well the physician said we took
several hours post testing to discuss
results which is not feasible in general
practice so between getting at this
issue that's been discussed widely in
the literature that you know in a
typical physician office visit that
lasts you know five to seven minutes
there's not enough time to go over you
know results like this from clinical
sequencing so how do we address this
issue
was pointed out by this particular
position the patient from case to one
point that she made was make it faster
so it's more relevant again getting at
another issue that's been discussed
widely which is turnaround time and how
can we lower that turned on time and
then finally ironically the father from
case three and you're probably not
surprised at this quote given the data
that I just showed you said do not
depend on a child's doctor to transfer
such important information which is a
pretty incredible quote when you when
you think about it you know the idea
that this father had had higher
expectations and and you know perhaps
felt that that there needed to be some
other system or for him to be able to to
get this information about his son and
from more of the quantitative measures
that we administered um we we looked at
kind of seek test related to stress or
sequencing related to stress and regret
we saw you know almost no distress among
these patients very little regret about
going through the study or anything like
that we also asked this group of
patients and physicians the extent to
which they felt that another clinician
should be involved in this process and
seventy-five percent of the physicians
and fifty percent of the patients
suggested that in that an additional
clinician should be involved two most
common types of clinicians mentioned
were a genetic counselor to better
understand between the genetic results
and then also a psychologist to help
patients kind of under understand or
deal with the implications of the
results for example whether or not the
results are actionable or whether or not
the results actually had a finding that
you know could could provide more
information about the diagnosis is not
all of our cases actually uncovered the
the genetic diagnosis and so what about
barriers I think we've encountered you
know a lot of the barriers that that
kind of leave the usual suspects the
barriers that many people are
experiencing who are trying to do this
type of work cost efficiency privacy
concerns turnaround time as I mentioned
too few genetic counselors one reason
that we utilize physicians as kind of
the primary point person to return
results is that there's so many more
physicians than there are genetic
counselors only about 3,000 in this
country genetic counselors so it's about
one for every hundred and thirty
thousand people and so if clinical
sequencing were to become much more
widespread there would be you know a
problem if we felt that genetic
counselors needed to be involved in each
and every case and so in in utilizing
physicians as a primary sort of point of
contact in our study we felt that it
would kind of be more ecologically valid
more to a real world if you will and
then also the issue of physician
training which has been again one of
these hot button issues that's been
widely discussed what you think what you
can see here this is a compilation of
some of the genomic medicine initiatives
in this country up until about spring of
this year I'm sure there are a few more
at this point in time there's about in
the and this is very encouraging a
number of these schools um sort of
developing genomic medicine curriculum
for undergraduates for medical students
and so forth but I think what's what's
important as a 16 initiatives but
there's actually over 140 accredited
medical schools so um you know this
isn't a new issue but certainly the
issue of physician training was sort of
looms large in this space another
that we're pursuing at Scripps to try to
you know further build on some of the
ideas and the results that we've seen an
idiom is actually a partnership with
several primary care in internal
medicine and family medicine physicians
here at Scripps who have signed on to
participate in a study where each of
them will enroll four to six patients
those patients will undergo sequencing
and these physicians have all signed on
to to try to return results to these
patients and further explore that
process and how we can effectively
integrate genome sequencing into the two
medicine turn into primary care so we're
we're looking forward to that initiative
so just to to conclude I want to revisit
kind of the main points that I mentioned
at the beginning of the talk and I think
one of the observations that I'm calling
these observations because this is case
study data this isn't a you know a large
randomized control trial but I think
we're seeing some hints that and
probably doesn't surprise anyone but
physicians as a group kind of need may
need help with genetics they and you
know and in some cases like our case
number three they might not know it so
um really you know kind of further you
know understanding these issues and
trying to figure out how we can increase
support for a physician and training is
obviously very important make another
important point and take home
observation is that in patients families
and physicians um would kind of more
often than not choose to receive some if
not all secondary or incidental findings
so kind of a message that these
individuals want access to their own
data want any and all data and findings
that are available and so thinking about
how to do that um how to
um you know potentially provide patients
with the choice about which ones which
findings they want to receive I think
further exploring that issue with
empirical studies is going to be
critical as I mentioned there's a lot of
commentaries and opinion pieces about
this but better understanding what is
the impact of delivering incidental
findings on the patients on the system
the healthcare system I think is going
to be important going forward and then
finally um just to underscore this point
again is that patients in these early
studies or at least in our early study
this diagnostic Odyssey type study are
not you know and I don't think this is a
surprise to anyone are not your average
patients and you know people who who may
be benefiting from sequencing in these
early stages are people who are kind of
area where are very savvy potentially
have a lot of financial resources so
thinking about how you know how we can
ensure that these services and this
technology is available to to all types
of patients who may benefit I think is
also important and I just want to
acknowledge a many people here at
Scripps who have made these studies
possible there's certainly has taken you
know the involvement for many people in
our group to to get the study off the
ground to to run these patients through
so very very appreciative here so that's
the conclusion of my talk um I'll take
questions now
okay so I have a one question here um
let me just read it an extremely
interesting study a number of
suggestions and hands appeared as far as
I understood five patients were enrolled
starting from approximately 100 eligible
cases you can for some metrics only four
cases were evaluated how did you address
the possible biases link to this low
recruitment rate have you planned
subsequent studies so this is a great
question I think just to you know it
kind of clarify a bit more we the
hundred cases that I that I mentioned in
the beginning we're actually not all
eligible these were all of our referrals
many of them you know did not come even
close to meeting our inclusion criteria
so we basically as I mentioned the
processes that for cases that appear as
though they might meet criteria we to
bring them forward to undergo panel
review by our clinician scientist panel
and then from there those that panel
actually chooses who to enroll and so
we've actually never had an instance
where the panel has voted to enroll a
case but that that family has declined
enrollment so I certainly agree that
that this is a very kind of bias
selected sample and I sort of intended
to elucidate some of those biases by
kind of showing you some of the patient
characteristics um but I don't know
hopefully hopefully that that kind of
clarifies some of those the questions
thank you for the question
okay so here's another question it can
based on the information you provided
could it be possible that genomics
screening data analysis and counseling
could be taken care of by private
industry rather than physicians patients
could then use such information to
subsequently go to a physician for
treatment only sounds like medic the
medical community could be overwhelmed
with the amount of work necessary I
certainly think that uh you know it with
you know I certainly think at this stage
in many cases the medical community is
overwhelmed with with you know all the
information that comes from genome
sequencing that's certainly been widely
discussed in literature I think you know
figuring out the best model for delivery
of genome sequencing is is is really
kind of a charge for the field and for
the community so you know whether or not
private industry you know would be the
place to do much of this work I don't
know i mean my sense is that ultimately
a partnership between the patient in
their physician with perhaps a lot of
support for the physicians may be a
better way to go but i think i think to
some extent it's an empirical question i
think we need to do the studies to
better understand you know what would be
optimal thank you for the question okay
so the next question um were there any
men minorities included in any of the
cases patient trust and cultural
competence of physician would be
important in the interpretations as well
or was there low response to the call
for per case and minorities um not I'm
sure I understand all the what's written
here in this question but I think the
general idea from from this is that you
know to what extent were
underrepresented minorities included in
the study it is a great question you
know out of the five cases that I
presented for them were of your
in background one was a Latina so I
think you know there is there's
certainly an issue with you know being
able to recruit sort of a more diverse
patient group and again there's
something I was sort of trying to get
out when I explained how you know these
patients are are not your average
patients they're highly educated they
have high incomes they are very savvy
you know they've worked the medical
system up until this point on their
diagnostic Odyssey and you can so I
think you know but in addition to that
and something I didn't mention but i
think is it's important and it thanks
for the question because it gives me a
chance to mention it is that you know
making sure there's a diverse sort of
ethnic racial representation in these
studies is critical
okay I'm not seeing any more questions
at this point but I'll wait a couple
more minutes if any of you have
questions please send me your questions
all right I'm not seeing any more
questions at this point of course feel
free to to email me if you if you have
any questions my email is C loss so CBL
OSS 15 at scripps edu i'm happy to to to
answer questions via email and i really
appreciate your attention and thinking
i'd like to thank the conference
organizers for inviting me to present
thank you very much